before we move on to the next story I
wanted to talk about this Vice report
that just also recently came out because
they detailed how seven years ago he was
also accused of sexual sexual assault
and physical abuse in the United Kingdom
but from that case the UK authorities
actually declined to prosecute him and
Tate released the statement about this
specifically through his lawyer while in
Romanian custody saying specifically
that the individuals accusing him were
trying to go after money saying quote
the police understood after the
investigation that I am innocent and the
police found messages from the girls
phones where they were talking between
themselves and planning to lie about me
end quote that's what Andrew Tate said
according to the response of this Vice
report that specifically detailed how he
punched one girl in the arm and
allegedly forced himself on another girl
in in a shower from one of the girls who
was who was seeing it uh the woman also
decided to remain anonymous here but
this Vice report is of course something
that everyone is talking about